un hôpital où l'on trouve de drôles de
passion lundi mardi à vélizy
l'association poèmes et ses étudiants en
médecine inscrits à l'université de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines ont
soigné des nounours et ils leur feront
encore jusqu'à vendredi à versailles
bonsoir à nos deux invités alexandre
majoulet et bonsoir apple tourelles
également vice président et responsable
communication de l'association alors
vous n'êtes pas nous tomber sur la tête
c'était une opération très sérieuse vous
soigner les nounours pour que les
enfants de moins de 7 ans globalement
soit moins inquiet lorsqu'il vont devoir
aller se faire soigner eux mêmes voilà
oui parce que le principe ils viennent
avec leur nounours leurs peluches sont
malades
c'est des enfants de dépasse de 6
enfants en grande section maternelle ils
ramènent leurs nounours ils choisissent
une maladie pendant une course et
ensuite ils passent dans les différents
services d'un hôpital fictif qu on a
reconstruit où ils soignent leur
nounours donc il ya un service de
radiologie un service simple que paiera
tout voir une salle de réveil
il ya aussi des filières paramédicales
comme que me deprez culte réservé aux
thérapeutes qui a décliné y aller donc s
avérèrent massy uniquement des étudiants
en médecine versailles saint quentin
sont membres de votre association qui
accueille ces différents enfants non pas
que ya des étudiants en médecine mais
aussi des étudiants dentaire en
pharmacie et comme j'ai déjà dit une
seule fonction sage femme alors les
enfants vient on les voit ses enfants
justement qui sont qui sont des écoles
avoisinantes là c'était sur vélizy cette
opération les enfants viennent avec leur
nounours et ils inventent leur maladie
ils vous donnent des symptômes ou vous
les guider un peu comment ça se passe en
fait on passe dans les écoles
un peu avant
ap avant l'hôpital ya une hausse et on
leur explique qu'il faudra ramener en
bourse va leur doudou un nounours lambda
et on leur donne des idées de maladie
pendant que la grippe ici cassé la jambe
de choses comme ça mais souvent les
enfants choisissent des maladies qu'ils
ont eu eux ou qui connaissent corps est
alors les résultats parce que l'objectif
c'est de dédramatiser l'hôpital est ce
que par exemple certains enfants qui
sont venus mais vraiment très inquiet
avec leur nounours malades oui il ya ça
dépend des enfants et des enfants qui
ont très peur y en a d'autres qui ont
menteur et au final ils étaient tous
très contents et généralement ils
étaient rassurés de faire les soins sur
leur nounours ça leur permet de
dédramatiser la chose
l'objectif est double parce que le but
c'est aussi de vous rassurer vous parce
que ce sont des enfants que vous pourrez
ensuite être amené à rencontrer ont
forcément s'intéresse pas aux maladies
des enfants de la même manière que les
adultes
pour les enfants c'est plus difficile
qui donnent leurs symptômes de
diagnostic est là aussi pour vous aussi
vous êtes rassuré à l'issue de cette
opération
oui c'est ça on peut on peut voir qui
sont les réelles craintes de l'enfant il
ya certains actes qui les dérange pas
trop il y en a qui sont vraiment
traumatisant pour eux ils aiment
vraiment les piqûres
ils ont très peur du bloc opératoire de
tout ce qui est ouvrir le corps des
choses comme ça c'est plus agréable de
voir les enfants dans un cadre autre que
hospitalier aussi vous allez accueillir
les enfants forcément
durant cette opération oui je veux pas
vous en attendez quoi vous êtes vous
êtes inquiet non non
vraiment c'est quelque chose d'agréable
longtemps et que dès mon retour pour
l'instant oui il est important que les
instants les étudiants sont dans mon
condo aussi est-ce que vous êtes formé
au cours de votre formation est ce qu'on
vous apprend justement à vous occuper
des enfants alors au cours de la
formation denis kalume bien entendu et
pour ce pour le projet de l'association
on a une lettre qui a été fait en un
pédopsychiatre qui nous apprend aussi un
peu comment justement pas dire de
bêtises face aux enfants ce que j'ai
quand même des mots qui peuvent les
marques et elle est traumatisée plus
tard bon on est quand même un peu un peu
accompagné à quel moment de la formation
intervient justement cette prise en
compte des enfants à quel moment on vous
l'apprends tout simplement les mots à
dire même si j'imagine ça s'apprend pas
véritablement ça sonne à vie au cinéma
terrain et on doit s'adapter aussi aux
enfants
on a quelques cours de psychologie quand
même un peu voilà le nom infantile et
c'est assez tard dans les études on fait
plutôt un troisième quatrième année
c'est aussi à travers les stages on peut
dire trupin exemple c'est vraiment là
qu'on apprend enfin en fait sur le tas
l'opération est menée par l'association
poèmes votre association c'est l'une des
principales missions de l'association
enfin dianor il ya trois pôles donc un
pôle de solidarité internationale un
pôle de solidarité locale et un pôle de
santé publique ont clairement dans le
camp dans le cadre de la santé publique
des actions de prévention d'éducation de
sensibilisation et donc on a d'autres
projets sur international donc
deux équipes qui vont partir au burkina
faso là cet été bah pareil pour des
actions de prévention d'éducation auprès
d'enfants collégiens au burkina avec cet
or lorsqu'on est étudiant on a le temps
de s'occuper d'une association étudiante
en médecine j'avais six ans on a le
temps bah en fait la première année
c'est une et qui est très lourde très
dur donc les étudiants en première année
s'occupent moins de l'association et
c'est plus et 2è 3è année qui vont
vraiment en fait de s'occuper c'est les
deux années entre guillemets les plus
agréables médecine où on a des cours
mais pas encore d'obligations suite à
l'internât on aura un nouveau un
concours qui est très dur en six ans en
6e année nous parlons ce soir notamment
des actions de l'action de l'association
poèmes mais principalement de cette
action l'hôpital des nounours je vous
invite d'ailleurs à vous rendre sur
notre site internet pour consulter le
reportage complet que nous avons
réalisés sur cette opération reportage
qui sera aussi diffusée dans là dessus
le tout images de la rédaction à 20h30
et à 22h sur tv fils est justement avec
cet hôpital des nounours nous avons
voulu savoir aussi si vous aviez
d'autres idées pour dédramatiser l
hôpital pour les plus jeunes c'est la
question que nous sommes allez vous
poser aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
mettre de la couleur met un peu de
peluches tous des activités pour les
enfants
oui des gens agréables également oui
nounours c'est pas mal ça nous a permis
à déguiser en nounours ça serait ça
serait génial
pas tout à fait laisser les parents avec
je pense que le fait d'avoir un endroit
qui ressemble plus à
a.diarra une école avec plein de dessins
et tout ça le plus de couleurs un peu
plus de oui c'est ça des jeux des
activités
une petite salle de jeux organisés par
exemple les visites d'hôpitaux dans les
écoles par exemple et dédramatiser
l'hôpital on accueille avec des délais
des couleurs quelque chose de très
coloré aider des gens très très souriant
et voilà et tout va bien des gens
souriants des médecins souriant c'est
important mais de la couleur aussi ça
change tout la couleur dans les hôpitaux
oui les enfants aiment bien la couche
déjà couleurs et ce tout ce qui est peu
luche sa salle et ça les calme vachement
et même des médecins souriant qui prend
qui prime c'est pour vous aussi parce
que lorsque vous intervenez lorsqu'on
est médecin qu on est professionnel il
ya beaucoup de travail
il ya des cas difficiles à gérer ça on
sait bien mais il faut quand même
prendre le temps se poser est toujours
mesuré ce qu'on dit est ce qu'on fait
pour les envois en portant on sent qu'on
peut vraiment les a posés entre
guillemets facilement leur parlant
calmement avec deux mots qui peuvent se
comprend l'hôpital des nounours
l'opération s'est déroulée
donc depuis lundi et mardi sur vélizy va
se prolonger jusqu'à vendredi sur
versailles ce n'est pas la première
année depuis quand c'est mener cette
opération par la société 2c fait déjà
six ans que satisfait et donc ça va se
poursuivre on imagine encore longtemps
oui c'est ça le sport
merci à vous de l'hôpital des nounours
donc et je vous disais tout à l'heure
le reportage complet sur cette opération
à suivre sur notre site internet et à
20h30 et 22h dans l'actu nous sommes
mercredi on passe à présent à la
chronique culture aurélia de vie si et
ses invités qui vont me rejoindre dans
un instant
avant de vous présenter notamment le
festival d'humour d'euros concours qui
va s'ouvrir dans quelques heures si vous
nous suivez en direct il est bientôt et
18h 30 ans ce mercredi voici les sorties
ciné chaque mercredi elodie moines va à
votre rencontre pour recueillir à la
sortie des salles aux impressions sur
les nouveaux films à la fiche
c'est en fin de compte c'est toujours
des films comme ça c'est sûr la
différence là c'est yahia lie à la ville
il ya un mur qui les sépare ya les
zombies à les morts j'adorais on sait
très bien c'est très bien ça ça donne à
réfléchir sur plein de choses
non franchement on se demande ce que
j'aime malkovich fait là dedans
franchement il va avoir besoin de
bouffer sans doute franchement non faut
pas aller voir sa première d'une amie
qui a beaucoup de
beaucoup d'action et en même temps bien
construit très bon moment à conseiller
j'ai bien aimé ça un bon film d'action
beaucoup d'explosions c'est plutôt un
bon film d'action
savants sont venus pas trop donc
on a des très bons acteurs
un bon scénario
donc ouais franchement c'était pas mal
c'est un très bon film
assez assez hard sur certains aspects
mais eux
si j'ai ça à réfléchir qui posent des
questions sur la région catholique voilà
donc non je trouvais intéressant mais
bon avec certaines longueurs